can you see us can you hear us this is
the beginning
blink thrice if you can hear me ryan
gosling has a chance of winning Best
Actor I hope so who's the first person
in our chat we need two Mouse's just
that way we can fight over it yes and
the computer won't know what to do when
we're doing yeah can you guys hear us
all right I hear a yes from a Brian
Burke what's going on oh this is might
be the first time here's a Meryl Streep
has a movie out an award season she's
not getting nominated for it oh so true
so true all right guys so we're gonna
talk about the Oscars the thing I care
the most about love them because last
year I won 50 bucks and a betting pool
at a party and I'm hoping I can win
again this year but I want to get a
general vibe from the people who are
here in the chat right now are you guys
upset with this stuff because it's easy
to go to Twitter
honestly I bet I like breeze through the
nominations and it's easy to go to
Twitter and just see everyone's pissed
off about something like every year or
everything on social media so I wasn't
that affected by it but yeah we'll dive
into some of the details soon but I want
to get a general vibe from what's going
on with you guys right now let us know
mm-hmm and always let us know if you
can't hear us you know what I mean
we got 99 eyes on us 99 eyes that sounds
like a oh wow okay oh okay people are
pissed mm-hmm people are upset some us
ire there's some Taron Egerton IRS Wow
JLo ire in here Wow
yep yep there's some anger in the chat
guys that Lapita knee I'll go really do
anything in us come on you know I mean
come on
did you this you're really uncut gems E
I hear a lot of people getting come on
feisty over that one come on come on
guys come on you guys if you guys are
getting too upset all right all right
now that we got a general bottom we've
got some eyes in here let's talk about
these
for nominations what should we start
with let's start let's go with the best
pictures and see what we got the deal
right let's start at the top
alright let's enter this into the chat
here okay so what are we oh we're gonna
adjust our faces
alright Best Picture nominees there's
not ten there are it's just blown up so
that everyone can see okay so what do we
got we got four V Farrar in which you
really liked I liked a lot I'm a little
surprised it's got a Best Picture
nominee er but okay the Irishman yeah
yeah alright okay I'll I respond well my
favorite was that your Jojo rabbit one
of my fare moves of the Year Joker
yes obviously once upon a time in
Hollywood
it's about Hollywood what do you expect
marriage story God you know I just can't
find myself watching that movie for
summary it just sounds like I'm gonna be
super freaking depress the whole time
parasite watch for the first time last
week that was great 19:17 I am watching
in exactly two hours from now at a
theater about 35 to 40 minutes away from
me so we end this at a sharp want to say
4:45 today and little women
I was also nominated for Best Picture
and so it's funny seeing this chat
because a lot of people are very excited
about Joker at the same time when I go
on social media everyone just seems
pissed off that Joker's got all these
Oscar nominations this is this is gonna
be a great year for divisive nominations
because people are angry that end game
only has a VFX nomination and also angry
that Joker got all these nominees yes so
let's close this out for a second so
guys which one is the one that you guys
are pissed off about that did not get
nominated for Best Picture because right
now I mean I feel like all these picks
are predictable they make sense to me
that they would get picked the Oscars
that like my favorite speech out the
Golden Globes was walking phoenixes
because this competition to art I'm just
sick of it like I said I just like being
in a betting pool and winning as much
money as I can from that okay Little
Women that's one end game I don't even
think about end game
they expect endgame to get in awesome I
never expected any gaming in an Oscar
nomination its endgame they feel like
there's like black panther makes more
sense to me because that's a little bit
more standalone whereas endgame is so
much of a culmination and Plus you know
it's gotten all the money in the world
let him have it let him have it yeah
yeah are there are there any Best
Picture nominee you wish got nominated
uh I uh could have seen us getting a
nomination in an alternate universe I
think that's a worthy film and an
interesting film yeah so yeah I think
that's a snub of sorts Jason Dolan says
the farewell should have received Best
Picture nomination I've heard that quite
a bit idea who Johnny Steven great
comeback Return of the King was a
culmination that's just three films that
and they awarded each of them at the
Oscars that's true so or at least
acknowledge them nominated each of them
at the Oscars John your cat's movie got
snubbed I'm so sorry about that Lee sad
about that but you know it'll become a
cult classic and that's what I really
want well Rocketman which i think is
undoubtedly better than Bohemian
Rhapsody
is not nominated for anything right not
that I am aware of even though the Taron
Egerton he won the Golden Globe nominee
for anything not that I am aware of I
mean you know seven Globes you get your
musical comedy category so you know I
think it's exactly what happened to
Sasha Baron Cohen for Borat won a Golden
Globe was a nominated for an Oscar same
exact same exact thing oh wait knives
out is not a Best Picture nominee nope
not not not at all okay that's upsetting
yeah yeah well that's really upsetting I
think a little more Ryan Johnson maybe
the Academy is still bitter about last
Jedi I'm seeing people here talking
about you know what you might call it a
little women I haven't seen that movie I
haven't seen that rendition yet but I
say rendition because it's like the
eighth seventh it was like the Pacific
the number like it's raising I know it's
not for there's so many little women
movies there are some I'm Kirsten Dunst
there's like four big theatrical
releases I think
and then there's like a whole bunch of
other versions as well let's let's
google it as a whole bunch as well so I
mean some people are really pissed off
that little women isn't nominated at
least seven at least seven of Little
Women see ya I watched Paris I last week
and I loved it I think that is the best
screenplay of the year and I think you
funny enough I think Joker and parasite
while two wildly different films they
comment on a lot of us some the same
things especially like Joker a little
bit more mental health and class
parasite a little more on class than
mental health they're kind of around the
same Moran and I feel like parasites
much better executed in that department
than Joker is out of all these okay so
let me ask you this I mean we're not
used to doing these but for Best Picture
which one of these Jon do you think
should win and from you guys which one
do you think out of the Best Picture
nominees should win Jon you go first
of this round I know you haven't seen
everything but which ones do you think
19:17 hands down for me okay or 1917 or
parasite I would say okay how did this
stable I would give the best picture to
because of all of these movies I mean I
think there is a lot of exciting
filmmaking but I think that 1917 in
parasite out of all of these that I have
seen are the ones where like every
aspect coalesce --is and the stories are
thrilling but also just the filmmaking I
found thrilling and inspiring and the
grip over craft whereas like for V
Ferrari I think is a really well-made
energetic movie I don't think it's
actually I wouldn't have put it in this
I'm happy to see it get a nomination but
I wouldn't have put it in here
necessarily well Jason don't thanks for
the super chat JT thanks for this camera
- by the way JD and thanks for your hi
patreon pledge JD thank you says once
upon a time in Hollywood will win best
pick I don't think you will I don't
think I don't think you well and nor do
I think it's the best there's no one in
this chat either who has said that it is
theirs I mean there's a few people yeah
but most people seem to be primarily
going for either Joker or pear
I've seen a lot of love here for the
Irishman right here I mean yeah some
people are voting for four of you
Ferrari now I've seen a little bit more
than half of these Best Picture movies I
would say my personal pick my personal
favorite would be Jojo rabbit out of all
of these you love Jojo now that's my
personal favorite the one that I think
should win marriage story I probably say
the one that should win would be
Irishman I would say that like it's big
its scope it's it does a period piece I
mean sure it falls in line with the Best
Picture nomination the one I would want
to see when is Jojo rabbit because
that's the one that communicated in my
heart touched my heart the most growing
up growing up as a Jewish survivor from
the Holocaust we really touched my heart
I really connected yeah I was like
finally I'm understood thank you thank
you so much yeah I am I am surprised
that they gave a parasite the Best
Picture nomination I'm not the best
foreign because like that's the kind of
loophole they went with for Roma last
year which is like it's guaranteed to
win Best Foreign who knows if it'll win
Best Picture so like that's a pretty
confident decision here parasites a very
universal even though it's like very
much focused on on class in Korea it is
very much a universal appeal I think I
saw a great meme somebody posted that it
had Arthur Fleck and it said all I have
are our negative thoughts and then the
next panel was just the parasite poster
and said hold my beer all right Elita
stands on Twitter thanks Carter loved
you I appreciate the elitist fans people
who just love love love Alita battling
are they upset it didn't get like a VFX
nod as I would at least be pleasantly
surprised if it had gotten one because I
but you know it broke some ground I feel
like I have enough time to catch up on
these Best Picture nominations are DJ
snug sorry about that but I think us is
a is a pretty big snub of the year I get
why it's not on Lara category but I
think for Best Picture I get why it's
not on here I feel like knives out
really is one of the best movies of the
year should have been nominated for Best
Picture and you know what [ __ ] it
and game is still my favorite movie of
hit a lot of friggin great movies and he
is still my favorite movie I know it's
not the cool thing to say I should say
something that's a little bit more artsy
like one of these or even Joker but no I
endgame is like that whole idea of just
a theory that's a because that's like a
the only movie this year um like I got
to keep going back to the theater and
it's designed for that and whatever you
hate me all you want for picking that is
my favorite movie the year but that's my
favorite movie hey man there are a lot
of angry people on Twitter who think
that the Academy is a bunch of fogies
who won't acknowledge the quality
filmmaking of the MCU Jason Dolan thanks
again buddy he says Buder bong haha keen
Boz El Vez if it misses sir and I'm
right there with you buddy know exactly
what you're talking about
director he's going bongju duty he he
made a movie around like I got I
immediately wrote down all his other
films instead of just realizing there's
an IMDB page I could just go do whatever
and I was like I gotta watch more of his
films yeah he's an incredible filmmaker
I have not seen that one movie let's
gang a show snowpiercer oh yeah that's
right Joaquin Phoenix alright let's go
through some other categories really
quick and then Niraj will talk about
your questioner I'll keep it up there so
don't forget let's go to Actress in a
supporting role what are you talking
about women are totally recognized this
year most in their supporting role
category surprise yeah no men got
nominated for Best Actress Kathy Bates
or Richard okay out of all the ones here
no I haven't seen all of them but the
ones that are I the one I hear the most
the absolute most about is Laura Dern
and marriage story I feel like that's
the yeah that's just I got a very
obvious pick yeah I don't think she'll
get the Golden Globe curse that that's
the buzz yeah I just feel like it'll
definitely go to order would she lose
two in the Golden Globes no she want it
oh so like but people say yeah like the
curse is that you have a Golden Globe
but yeah like of all these and like
Scarlett Johansson's gonna cancel
herself out I think bombshell hasn't
gotten quite the amount of traction
would have hope yeah and little women I
think the ensemble aspect is gonna
overshadow that I'm seeing a lot of love
here for the lighthouse and how that
should have been the nominations mid
Samar as well and a lot of love in the
chat here I love hearing the guys
through reading a guys feedback okay
laura dern that seems to be the name
main pick here near Raj asked us
interesting none of the 824 movies are
nominated for Best Picture they're
usually not they're usually a to an
issue or makes them too edgy of material
there should be a special category for
best day 24 all right let's move on to
another category John okay listen then
we'll move on to a another super chat
actor in a supporting role we got Hank Z
for a beautiful day in the neighborhood
we got Hopkins for the two popes Pacino
for the Irishman Pesci for the Irishman
and Brad Pitt for once a time and upon a
time though in Hollywood do you know
okay
the glowing one I haven't seen as the
two popes Pesci is my pick what do you
guys think she'd get Best Supporting
Actor past she's personally my pick I
think Brad Pitt's great and wants to
plus I'm in Hollywood Tom Hanks Tom
makes was just one of those roles it
like he said he's fantastic in it but
it's also like yeah I expected Tom Hanks
to do that does that make sense yeah
yeah I didn't have that experience but
yes I mean here the cats like I saw the
documentary and then what you hear
they're making this movie I'm like we'll
talk it should be Tom Hanks yep Tom next
it did the thing I wanted
yep he did it and he's amazing but the
one that I think delivered what you
wanted but also gave something different
granted I haven't seen two popes Joe
Pesci and the Irishman that's the one
that I think we all expected like loud
hang you call me a [ __ ] clown kind of
guy but I thought well we got a totally
different kind of role and I think Joe
Pesci gave it the best subtle
performance Pacino is a close second for
me though yeah the only thing I feel
like the Academy would be more inclined
to award one of those two for this movie
especially I just wonder if they'll have
that canceled out factor because I've
heard a lot of buzz about both of them
maybe because yeah and so I feel like if
any one movie with two noms could cancel
it is
I feel like a good chance for this one
just because a lot of people be voting
for both alright so we got a totally
random talk whose daddy
hey host the talk show thanks buddy for
a super check called totally random talk
like to interview you John and Greg for
season two if interested message me
thanks big fan Oh would you shut an
invite oh sweet
this is how I wish you get all our
invites every we'll just do any
interview our rates for an interview
$1,000 apiece yes we are that value
minimum minimum our insight and time is
of the essence but no hit us up we're
more than happy to talk how long is your
show can we live stream in if I have to
drive there I'm gonna be a little bit
more hesitant appreciate you just the
same all right let's move on God John do
your research let's scroll down we
haven't seen any of these original song
oh we got a little Rocket Man okay we
got I'm standing with you from
breakthrough into the unknown from
frozen to stand up from Harriet I'm
gonna love me again from Rocket Man and
I can't let you throw yourself away
frozen to into the unknown that's the
one I pick right there oh not even a big
frozen to fan but I would pick that one
that didn't get animated feature
nomination did it nope that was another
one that people were up in arms about
gosh no that's too upsetting
I'm bummed that I it's cut everyone's
gonna be frozen to Mary Steenburgen
right she like wrote a song for this
movie and has like a she she had like
some kind of head trauma and then
developed like the ability to make music
and so I'm bummed that she didn't get
nominated for this category but yeah
alright animated feature film what do we
got
stranger dragged in the hidden world I
lost my body Klaus from Netflix edging
out frozen to missing link and Toy Story
4 has How to Train Your Dragon 1 any of
the animated feature films I feel like
one of them may have
that wasn't my favorite one of the
trilogy but it's one of those things
where it's like just give it it them
because I mean I think Klaus is the one
that people like for the people have
actually seen the animated features
I feel like Klaus is going to be the one
that people vote for but how to change
your dragon in a world my heart's just
like give it to them just do it to them
they deserve it after all the hard work
but yeah yeah and and I mean I think it
would be really cool if Klaus could get
some love just because the Hat it's like
if the Golden Globes could give the
animated feature to the claymation one
of the Oscars can do it for the
hand-drawn I think that would be two
really nice votes of confidence for two
modes of animation that are you know
lacking in the marketplace that I think
a lot of people would love to see
research you know and not just be one
studio each you know or something like
that
okay adapted screenplay here we go my
kind of category look out alright the
Irishman that is a hard script to adapt
yeah that that's not like the structure
in that movie very challenging Jojo
rabbit hmm
little what you see the thing honestly
now that I'm not being sexist I'm more
like it's the seventh one
maybe it's super special for being the
seventh in addition and I might sound
like a hypocrite co-stars Bourne was my
favorite movie of last year but come on
it's the seventh movie of Little Women
how drastically different can it be am I
totally off here see the people in the
Chad let me know am I am I totally off
about little woman there's a reason I
haven't been like anxious to go check it
out hmm Joker is it really an adapted
though I feel like that's a loophole
kinda yeah maybe I guess for the most
part of qualifies as adapted yeah
alright okay my pick for this one Jojo
rabbit because that is I mean a la Costa
directing not and also I don't remember
offhand who was nominated for directing
but I would have to say that is a hard
tone to ride and Jojo
rabbit every almost every second of that
movie if it was like this could be too
offensive this could be not pushing the
boundaries in the it had a really hard
line to ride and I think in terms of
like characters and humor and bouncing
it with really hard-hitting drama III
think Jojo rabbit that's that's the one
right there
I'd love to see Jojo take that and maybe
that'll be the one place they award it i
thinkin maybe and yeah for the messaging
if not Jojo I think it would be the
irishman also shouts out to Polly V I
was trying to superimpose you're a super
chat here but it's too far down the list
now I'm sorry but Adam Sandler and uncut
gems thoughts don't worry don't worry
about being late we haven't seen it
either so we're very late I'll say this
I think Adam Sandler has for the longest
time been a highly underrated dramatic
actor I've gone to like that's what I've
been wanting him to do and I'm I am very
much like I'm anxious to watch that
movie but I also feel like I gotta be in
the zone cuz I hear it's like an anxiety
attack because you're gonna be even more
here's like such a like a tense
experience that I really want to be more
in the zone to check it out but yeah
John are these adapted which one would
you say is your pick um I personally
would go with Jojo rabbit and I think
that if not Jojo it'll be the Irishman
all right all right well while we pull
up next category we go busy our screen
is so much no I know Jason would have
loved to seen Florence Pugh get a nom
her performance in midsummer was
absolutely haunting and disturbing and
stayed with me I agree i liked midsummer
a lot and and i think there are a lot of
worthwhile elements to that movie and I
think maybe arias you're just like
because of hereditary and because most
people agree that hereditary is me is
like has a bit of an edge on midsummer I
feel like that's probably why it's not
very loved this year and yeah okay well
thanks a cos Jason Akash what a cool
name what does that mean
yet Florence pew and Lapita Nyong'o well
being younger I think it is as a lot of
credibility and even though she wasn't
totally she was totally snubbed
I feel like she's a little
more in the zeitgeist when it comes to
these voting circles in Florence pew I
really think it's gonna be a superstar I
mean she was the one in the fighting my
family amazing in that movie I don't
know if you care about accuracy don't
think about that but it's sort of a
performance she's great in that movie
yeah and then with her coming out in
Black Widow I really think she's gonna
be a superstar so even though she a lot
of people have expressed that sentiment
amid some art I also think she's gonna
be someone down the road who almost
certainly be nominated if not win one
day so don't you worry for Florence to
see the pizzas she ever won for anything
how does she win to supporting for 12
years I think she might have yeah uh I
suppose could be wrong about that
Lana Pico or I will talk about Lana's in
a second all right Original Screenplay
marriage story
once upon a time in Hollywood I did it
parasite knives out of night oh that is
tough for me once upon a time oh that's
that's a toss-up parasite or knives out
for me parasite I would say parasite oh
yeah yeah it's either parasite or knives
out for me I mean I I enjoy its upon a
time and I like Tarantino's writing but
I think that especially in this category
knives out in parasite are both just so
sharp and fine yeah that I would be
happy to see either of those walk away
with it for sure I mean I I think oh
yeah parasite I think it was easier to
appreciate the script for parasite
because I have to read it you have to
read every this of the dialogue um but
that just never went at all how I
I think knives out is probably the most
clever film of the year like that is
just that's clever that's fun
yeah but parasite I think parasite out
of all those movies is the one all these
you can argue that you get more from it
every time but parasite its additional
nuance and context on what it's talking
about and literally every scene its
structure that's the move that probably
just like [ __ ] disturb the [ __ ] it's
time yeah very watching experience its
commentary I
I was in love with so yeah I would I
would say parasite I'm for my personal
pick what about you guys
which one here do you think deserves
Best Original Screenplay and Lana says
UK Lana cook a dish several times and
improve the recipe and taste Gretta did
this with Little Women
much like Bradley Cooper did with a star
is born
ah fascinating out fighting words oh you
can cook a dish I'm prisoner okay all
right all right Lana all right listen
Little Women I actually I was at a party
and there was a guy a total bro oh no he
was playing beer pong and he was on New
Year's and he said and he was talking
about uh he was talking with Olivia and
he said you know little woman I saw that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm prejudging and I know that
I'll admit it I'm free I feel like it's
probably a really good movie I'm just
not like it's probably the last one I'm
gonna check out yeah yeah yeah
Tortelli Anita thank you so much buddy
thank you that really appreciated since
Tyler didn't get a nomination you better
keep his promise to make the worst film
ever made also super happy ryan johnson
connor for original screenplay I did
think it would happen but glad he got
the recognition you know speaking of
that note I'm really glad that knives
out wasn't just met with a whole bunch
of yeah but remove the worst [ __ ] like
it seems like a lot of people were
incredibly uh reciprocated reciprocating
they were they were very open to it it
seemed like I want to use a bigger work
okay we're reciprocating is when you
return something
imitating is returning something in kind
but I know where you're going and I'm
trying to find the word to receive
receptive receptive receptive we did it
guys so why there's jump cuts in the
YouTube videos and not in the live
streams um yeah
totally agree yeah I'm really glad that
movie got nominated actor in a leading
role a cos means sky Niraj has helped us
out Thank You Niraj actor in a leading
role what do we got Antonio Banderas
painting that's a foreign film right I
believe so yes a Almodovar that's why I
haven't seen it is it ain't American
yeah hey but hey that's all parasite and
here's at least one non white guy
nomination who Antonio Banderas is not
technically a white guy Tony Flags my
man my man flags over DiCaprio for once
upon a time all right I haven't seen
marriage story yet Adam drive it's a
hundred percent a competition between
Adam driver and Joaquin Phoenix yes I on
leave that undoubtably
yeah I think Joaquin Phoenix has really
demonic Joker's got a lot I feel like
the Oscars were like look this is a
comic book movie we could get behind
okay we can move the Joker
award count was yeah very much smack to
me of like this is one yeah there you
perfectly fits the Venn diagram of
cinema and not never we can make people
happy now maybe this won't not be so mad
that we didn't nominate endgame for
everything well they're not gonna win
most of them but you know and I feel
like it probably won't but it probably
will win this cat I think why I'm with
you English well there's a it's a
combination of it's kind of like what I
was saying How to Train Your Dragon I
think she is gonna probably take
something probably won't blow I think it
should
what are they call where it's like the
the longevity award hurts like they're
but not a jillion time just give it its
like yeah it's the oh yeah what do you
call that out of respect you know yeah
the longevity award like you've been
around for so long you've been holding
it down we got to recognize you
somewhere and I feel like as good as
DiCaprio is like that's probably gonna
dog him for this because he finally got
it when he that was his longevity or
epidemic yeah and then walking Phoenix
same thing and plus with all the hype
around him I'm not saying he's not
deserving of it I just feel like it it's
he's leaning a little bit more towards
him I think he's the easiest part of
that movie to agree on for everyone and
I think that of
all the splashes that movie made his is
the widest biggest I mean in terms of
original screenplay
there is Eclipse going around on Twitter
of it demonstrating how great every line
of dialogue not overly expositional
Paulie vo we recovered actress and a
leading role here we go ladies lose
Cynthia areevo Harriet I am ashamed of
myself for I haven't seen it he asked
John for the longest time I've been
saying I should make a Harriet Tubman
movie yeah longest freakin time and you
wanted to write it why I want her to
write it yeah a matter of fact I wanted
to make a craft novel out of it
that could be cool still and I never
even bother to watch it
I remember one time at movie fights mark
and Draco was talking about how they
should make one - no it's like obviously
there for years yeah and I for some
reason I haven't seen it you know I
thought Scarlett Johansson was the for
sure winner man I'm not looking good
here at all I don't think I see a lot of
targeted towards me this is the problem
were the problem we're the problem of
why not enough woman are getting this is
the actress like the filmmaking category
is different the Actress category leave
a gig out there are gonna be actresses
and an actress it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect this category that we
didn't see from the trailer Renee
Zellweger and Judy just seems like the
ideal pick well and it says it's a good
story - it's like she's been out of the
spotlight and she has like had trouble
getting back in the spotlight so that
would be a nice redemption arc for her
and yeah I just feel like I haven't it
doesn't seem like bombshell has had the
teeth they hoped it would and I wonder
if maybe with Scarlett Johansson you
know we're also just a little you know
Scarlett it out after so many different
like little controversies and things
like that I don't know and it's also I
feel like marriage story while I've
heard it's terrific and I like
the first act that I saw you know I feel
like there are I feel like it's a very
quintessential kind of Oscar performance
maybe they'll go different route okay
right here I'm gonna watch this movie in
90 minutes
mm-hmm but based off everything I've
heard it seems like Sam Mendes is gonna
win for 1917 if I had to narrow it down
to one award I think I would give it to
him especially hearing about how they
made correcting yeah cuz the direct
again because so much of that movie was
sculpted around the actors in rehearsal
and you know so much of it like
everything was built around rehearsing
with those actors and like that was like
Sam Mendes yeah sculpted that movie so
so much yeah so uh but I would love I
mean like I think he is hands down the
winner for me but I would love to see
bong joon-ho take it you know well fund
me production says Eddie Murphy was
snubbed give Eddie Murphy some love at
least at the Golden Globes but I was
happy for Terron edited but I thought
Eddie Murphy would win that actually I
mean I guess they just don't like
comedians who do dramatic work yeah I've
never they like think you're good
because you're rarely serious wasn't
even serious in that I mean serious at
times it's a comedy you know so pretty
much Eddie Murphy mm-hmm
I mean you gotta you gotta take it into
it account you know like a grand I
haven't seen all I've seen most of those
best actor performances you got taking
account too
it's like what do you consider a snub R
is it like no this person should have
been not nominated and this person
should be nominated yes they're like a
bad choice always suggests that these
five were all deserving and we can't
have six yeah yeah exactly you know but
hey I guess so
Archer PA saw 1917 the best director
category is stat it is a stacked
category but Todd Phillips for Joker I
think he directed like all the time
filler your joints I'm impressed with
his job on that movie and the only
kneecap I would give him as that you
know up score says he's also in this
genre and that movie is like a hybrid of
two Scorsese
so you know well give it to Todd
Phillips when you have Martin Scorsese
in the category but then again Tarrant I
mean Tarantino gained script nomination
I see but Tarantino what he went how he
director once upon a time Hollywood is
not entirely different from a lot I mean
he brought the 1970s a lot of like a lot
of production as I went into that but in
terms of directing I feel like we've
there's some great direction in it but I
feel like of all of his movies it's not
necessarily yeah maybe just because it's
new wavier and it's less flashy about
its directing you know it's it's a
little less intrusive of a movie until
it shifts tone thanks yeah
well thank you Jason bong joon-ho
director Roger Deakins cinematographer
on Roger James Dukes yes Dukes hey
what's going on in the Philippines these
things for pray for the dumb how
Filipinos like how to know what's going
on you guys can inform me at really
appreciate Philippines is it's not on
fire is it Jason Dolan thank you again
Phillip stretch of best acting
performance of the year that's true and
and Joaquin Phoenix does credit him a
lot for that yeah there's a lot that
goes into direct you never might not
even actually you know I am it was that
was of the variety breakdown of the
opening scene was a variety the top
folks that they made me go well I was
kind of a lot more direct in that that
is fair I mean what other did what other
directors do you think should be
nominated though put in the chat some
some love for tyka in here I mean what
do we think about the fact that no
female director was nominated wait I
think it's a drag females make movies
does he just started they just got the
right we voted in a new a new amendment
to the Constitution and now women can
direct movies
I don't remember voting on that mmm yeah
I know I don't know that and that's why
you got to be involved with the society
that you live in get out and vote 2020
pretty soon they'll let women write
movies too I I'm fascinated by this a
volcano erupted in the Philippines Jesus
Christ no I'm gay I gotta look into a
charity for that yeah goddamned things
you learn unlike Jesus right oh man okay
I gotta look into a charity for that
we're talking about we got to redirect
this back that I'll go online all that
talk about Todd Phillips I'm not sure
let's look at the other ones production
design once about time in Hollywood
Irishman 1917 Jojo okay often without
having seen 1917 I will in eighty
minutes remember yeah I would say once
upon a time Hollywood I feel like once
upon a time in Hollywood has the edge
because you know I feel like that movie
is not going to coast as much as a lot
of other movies have on being a
nostalgic Hollywood film but the way
they recreated it I think is one of the
most celebrated aspects of that movie
that being said again because 1917 is so
physical and they basically just had to
build everything to scale and and really
construct all these trenches and no
man's land like it because of the way
that movie has realized the production
design and the like there's no place to
hide anything so they really just had to
build it without cheating so I think
there is something to be said for that
movie just in the undertaking of making
it possible you know well looking
through this list of some bringing it
back to the female directors Lulu Wang
for the farewell that's a movie that was
75 percent in and not in English but it
was still like distributed as an
American film and she did an incredible
job with that and then also oh damn I
didn't know a beautiful day in the
neighborhood enou who directed that oh
wow oh wow
Wow honey boy yeah which I've heard a
lot of love for and I think it just
hasn't had the the scope
you know the breadth of reach and Queen
and slim mm-hmm Malina Mantzoukas who
has done some great great TV work and
now he has is
into the motion sounds to me like honey
boy was out of the female directors who
were the most snub I would say honey
boys the one mm-hmm well I mean or Lulu
wing Lulu Wong I think she I think yeah
she has probably the biggest edge for
the snub argument I mean I really
appreciate it what Mary Lou Heller did
in recreating the the mr. Roger show
format in the movie but uh but yeah I
definitely think there were some very
deserving it's like I might have knocked
a couple people out of the directing
category for at least yeah like Lulu
Wong or somebody um okay so we'll get to
this question in a second cinematography
1917 once Motown Hollywood the Irishman
Joker the lighthouse lighthouse got a
nomination for that that's cool maybe
it'll sneak up and win from just seeing
the trailers I am watching in 75 minutes
to leave 1970 yeah just watch the
trailers I'm like this is probably the
best shot movie of the year like it just
looks like it yeah I mean and yeah again
it's just a cinematography like the
amount of in-camera figuring out they
had to do was in sit like the amount of
like we're on a Steadicam and now the
Steadicam guys getting on a truck and
now it's on a crane like it's insane
Archer PA I'm a bit of norther there
were no female there were no females no
females involved not even in the Best
Actor supporting all dudes nominated for
the actress category now you're not the
only one who feels that way and then
honestly add to like Google like what
films were directed by women this year
that's what I was doing over here and I
was like oh damn there were a lot of
MOOC and you know like it says something
on my end for not paying enough
attention to that but it also shows
something that they they're not put in
the spotlight enough for the film's they
direct but then whenever a guy like the
people who are nominated for director
like yeah I hear their names all the
time on all these sites but I rarely
hear about the woman who directed some
pretty amazing films yeah you hear about
the films and other aspects of me but
you now hear about that as a woman who
did it
name at least not enough like roediger
wig I think because of what you do labor
you hear her name a lot but and because
she's got the acting you know true name
built up already
a tress in Venice could you guys please
write to star wars read five Top Gun
member oh thanks dude um well let's save
the link and maybe we'll do it here but
if we have time before I go but yeah let
me screenshot your thingy and I'll make
sure well yeah we need some video we
don't have enough video cover right
happens all right
directors what do I expect from the
character I'm sorry I'm sorry you know
the Oscars nominations tend to be like
presidential elections hmm it's like we
always pendulum swinging yeah you know
yeah we're like not black enough low a
lot of black people then a lot of white
people know this I feel like next year
really gonna be like what are they get
mad at us about Oh like this year's like
okay we got your lunch okay all right
next year let's get a lot of women in my
like this is the way we it's all
political it is and that's why I don't
feel like this art comparison is not the
greatest hmm um so let's see here what
do we got here costumes probably little
women I feel like I feel like that may
be where they award gonna be probably
cuz the pretty dresses guys women right
like sound editing hey Rises sky you
know rides Skywalker did have pretty
awesome sound design I will say that
that's kind of punch Ford V Ferrari I
thought had a great sound design because
that really the the revving and and all
the you know little cockpit noises
really did enhance the intensity Joker
got a sound editing what soundings set
out to you in Joker don't ask me I don't
know Joker I yeah and I feel like I
don't know you could have put an end
game in here too sure yeah something not
to not to take away from Joker but at
the same time maybe because they use the
scribe or something sometimes but they I
don't know I feel like lighthouse yeah
yeah well I I mean on my house does any
one of my favorite movies at the
year but lighthouse sound editing that
one way deserved I mean I feel like it's
probably gonna be for V Ferrari I feel
like that would be a nice one for it to
win just beginning to really remember
the sonic experience of that movie two
tons of diversity in the Spirit Awards
that's awesome to hear well then let's
review those number the time next time
mixing you know the sounder are editing
and sound mixing usually go hand in hand
it's I know but usually that's like they
go hand in hand
it'll be ad astra for sure alright
Original Score oh I hope the Joker score
wins you know I feel like it I feel like
it's it probably might be the
front-runner and it is a haunting and a
four man that's an opportunity for the
Academy to parade their woke miss as
they award a woman in a non female
oriented category hey don't make fun of
us sorry we all can't get laid like you
there's a reason double toasted as the
better than sex alright thank you so
much Lynnae you're so sweet my dear so
sweet alright visual effects here we go
oh thank god yeah and I really hope it's
anybody there really over thank you I
really do hope there's an argument to be
made for Lion King because of how
photorealistic it is but and it's the
most successful part of that movie is
the visual effect the end game did a
great job like there were things in
there that I had no idea where via like
we watched that whole VFX breakdown and
I was like what yeah yeah I feel like in
my mind the white it's the widest
breadth of visual effects techniques
employed in all manners like you've got
a CG mocap lead you've got you know all
the different characters and backgrounds
but you have also got aging up and aging
down and yeah you've got a ton of things
in your repertoire so one Thank You Jean
thanks gene Jeter once upon time in
Hollywood real rejects didn't start in
1917 watched by the little woman
spinnin chokers it's always a Greg John
good good time starring Robert Pattinson
directed by the Softee brothers who were
not nominated go and cut Jim go to gene
Jeter's channel man yeah oh he's a
fantastic human being thanks gene and
thank you again Len a film editing ooh
they are okay honestly I can see Ford
may be taking this because again like
the amount of intensity that that movie
had to convey and one of the biggest
notes of that movie for me was that
people who don't care about racing were
very wary of it and a lot of them wound
up enjoying it and I think again a lot
of that has to do with the construction
and the energy with which that movie was
assembled but continue I definitely have
something set please
I would say the Irishman okay it's
Martin Scorsese's endergirl because that
is a lot of people not everyone's gonna
agree with this a lot of people have
said like for a three and a half hour
film that you don't even really notice
the runtime they barely note it's like
that's you'll notice it because three
and a half hours but you're not like
what's gonna [ __ ] it the other thing
too is that movie had like I think 2500
have a good ridiculous amount of shots a
ridiculous like the most out of any
movie this year the hands down and it
flowed it was fluid it was wonderful and
so I I would I would personally give it
to the Irishman for that one I I would
as much as I would be like pleased to
see four taken I think Irishman is well
deserving as well you see okay that are
all deserving that's pointing out that
uncut gems are great editing too
that's another thing I'm that's what I
mean like an intense hot experience
that's what I'm okay
Lance we're gonna do a new livestream
tomorrow being like I changed my mind
everything 1917 deserves all the awards
thanks Lance appreciate it but it gets
special I hope you voted for me in that
Shmona an award that I lost Lance it's
all I care about
yeah man where's your where's your
loyalty makeup and hair styling pitch
bombshell Joker Judy Maleficent in 1917
I feel like it's gonna make Joker just
because on the strength of the eye
anok makeup alone Oh God nineteen seven
no a lighthouse lighthouse should have
been a bit yeah oh come on yeah what the
hell why'd you spill your beans and
whoever did the makeup on JLo's ass and
hustlers they should have been nominated
Oh hair was great oh it got a nomination
JLo that would have been that would have
been cool I guess Maleficent is the most
out there in terms of makeup and Harold
or maybe Judi for the transformation
sake but part of me just feels like the
Joker is it might take that a bombshell
they make sure their hair was really
blonde but also Charlize Erin's makeup
and one isn't there a Roger Ailes in
there something I think we did it we've
done it we did it guys we've reviewed
the movies thank you to everyone who
stayed in this live stream we're not
used to doing these and especially
something like this yeah but we're gonna
get people used to convert at this photo
we need so you know we got to see the
people I need a head out to go well
we're talking I like John wick and stuff
yeah I mean I think that they should
wear stuntman cast or in that category
should be there should be more
categories I think that's Oscar Sun team
there shame you know sambal category I
don't know why not everyone seems really
pissed off about uncut gems gems and
cats man that a few names I've said out
of all the ones that are being that they
were like the most talked about terms of
snubs uncut gems seems to be the number
one I'm seeing God's I love her
mentioned a few times sure but uncut
gems is like that but weirdly or we were
talking about this that sometimes a snub
can have long like DiCaprio for Django
or Jake Gyllenhaal for Nightcrawler
sometimes that just makes people love
those movies that much more people will
remember that longer than who probably
even one that you should avoid yeah yeah
and I think like Adam Sandler not being
nominated has a bit of a bit more legs
on it anything else honestly yeah I'm
surprised for it as much buzz as I have
heard in as many people as I've heard
hailing both the movie and that
performance I am very surprised it's got
no love here
you know and lupita like Luke Pizza does
make me mad like that she didn't get
anything for us like Lupita I think if
it has to do with genre I guess because
it's not because of the fact that it's
damn you can't really spoil the movie
that she's giving like two films worth
of acting in one movie but at the same
time it's like the character is not
fully human in a way of like you know
weird I don't know how to put it I don't
know I don't know how to go into it
without ruining the [ __ ] movie for
people so that's I don't know
yeah whatever anyway yeah I agree lon
okay I'm feeling anxious right attitude
I gotta get going thank you guys so much
for being here this was fun we want to
do a little bit more topics and open
mics this is this this is new for us
figure in this F show me [ __ ] on screen
thank you to everyone who contributed to
the super chat by the way that means a
hell of a lot showing out your
hard-earned cash thank you so much
we need outros only you need an outro
guys comment on the video when it's
reposted to YouTube with your snubs and
favorites there we go like hit that
subscribe if you somehow are here
without having subscribed and we'll see
you on the next live chat be well
oscar's